- We'll get five random suggestions,
we'll divide you guys up,
and then a freestyle rap will occur.
If you are over here, what
would you like a rap about?
- [Man] Chrysanthemums.
- Chrysanthemums, are they
your favorite flower, sir?
- [Man] No, I just thought
it was an interesting word.
- No, you just thought it
was an interesting word.
Well, do you have a favorite flower?
- [Man] Sunflower.
- Sunflower?
What a shit favorite flower.
(audience laughs)
Wow, it's one of the worst flowers.
It's the ease that...
Flowers should be judged by their rarity
and difficulty to grow.
Like Peonies, you only get them
for like a month of the year
and they're fucking bastards to open.
(audience laughs)
And you're just like
a thing that a three-year-old can grow,
(audience laughs)
and put in a seed.
Fine but Chrysanthemums, nice.
And let's come to you guys over here.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Woman] Substitute
teacher that fell asleep.
- Substitute teacher that fell asleep.
Fantastic, thank you very much.
Chrysanthemums, a substitute
teacher who fell asleep.
Middle of the room.
So far these are two
very good suggestions,
don't let me down.
- [Audience] Schrödinger's Cat
- Amish people that use...
- There were two.
So you said Schrödinger's
cat, and you said?
- [Guy] Amish people that use
manual tractor things
instead of actual tractors.
- Ah, cool, yeah.
(laughter)
Amish people who use manual
tractor things instead of...
So you mean like the ones that
are like pulled by people?
- [Guy] Pulled by horse.
- Pulled by horses, okay, cool.
I guess they're one step above me.
I'd be such a shit Amish person.
(audience laughs)
Like, "Oh I can't believe
I've got to drag this."
Everyone else is like, "Use a horse."
(audience laughs)
Robots.
And Schrödinger's cat,
okay cool, so manual
tractors for the Amish,
Schrödinger's cat, substitute teacher
who fell asleep, chrysanthemums.
Back corner over here, what
would you like a rap about?
- [Lady] A white man for the first time
in the Philippines.
(audience laughs)
- Okay.
(applause)
- Bit weird, innit?
But okay.
(laughter)
And people over here, what
would you like a rap about?
- [Dude] Homeless people on the subway.
- Homeless people on the subway.
Are you yourself a homeless person?
- [Dude] Absolutely.
- Yeah?
(laughter)
Okay, just feels like a kind of
mean-hearted suggestion, doesn't it?
People who through probably
no fault of their own
are on hard times and
need somewhere to shelter.
Partly down to this country's
horrendous treatment
of veterans and the poor, okay.
- [Person] Fuck that guy.
Well, homeless people on the
subway, Amish manual tractors,
Shrödinger's cat, a first
person, white person.
- [Lady] Old man, old
man in the Philippines!
- I didn't know you said
old man, you said white-
- [Lady] Old man.
- But they're old, okay.
- [Lady] Old white man.
- They're old and white.
They're two of the
worst things you can be.
(audience laughs)
I mean now, right?
For the 0.1 percent history we're in,
for the rest of time
it's been banging.
(audience laughs)
Chrysanthemums,
substitute teacher who fell asleep.
Okay, that's like one or two more
than usually I take but we'll do our best
to try and fit them all in.
(audience talking)
This then lovely people,
I'm gonna ask you guys to be
my little DJ booth down here.
This is a freestyle that is a rap made
up on the spot based
entirely on suggestions.
Not written, not prepared, not rehearsed
and do not worry your pretty little heads.
It'll not be anywhere near as atrociously,
embarrassingly, toe-curlingly bad
as you're expecting a properly
educated middle class
white British boy to be.
I'm very excited and
those are very nice shoes.
Well done, cool.
Let's have some delightful fun.
We're starting with yours sir.
Cool.
♪ Yeah, we wanna start
the rap the fun way ♪
♪ but we've gotta tackle out
the bloke on the subway ♪
♪ Looking at the homeless ♪
♪ looking at the bums ♪
♪ saying let me shout it out ♪
♪ I know it will be fun ♪
♪ He ain't got no shoes ♪
♪ I can see his toes ♪
♪ through the socks on
the end of his feet ♪
♪ cause those holes ♪
♪ tell me he's been sleeping rougher ♪
♪ out in the little street you know ♪
♪ he can't trust gotta
get somewhere safe ♪
♪ Maybe not insane ♪
♪ So he's there underneath
the seats on the L train ♪
♪ I've seen it ♪
(cheering)
♪ it's happened before ♪
♪ a guy's been sleeping and
he's blocking the door ♪
♪ I'm like well sir ♪
♪ See the sign? ♪
♪ You should check it, respect it ♪
♪ Don't block the emergency exit ♪
♪ He looks at me, ♪
♪ he be like like wowser ♪
♪ and he makes me run away by
whipping down his trousers ♪
(audience laughs)
♪ take a chance, there's
holes in his pants ♪
♪ A substitute teacher ♪
♪ Dare I have a glance ♪
♪ see him up the front of the room ♪
♪ in front of the whiteboard ♪
♪ I say looks like he's snoozing ♪
♪ I'm not quite sure ♪
♪ So I check it out ♪
♪ I take a bit of paper ♪
♪ I bundle it up into a
sphere and I make sure ♪
♪ I've got the aim like
my name's Steph Curry ♪
♪ and it hits him on his head
he doesn't wake up in a hurry ♪
♪ He be snoozing, ♪
♪ head up in the chalk ♪
♪ I walk over me and my classmates talk ♪
♪ We're like, ♪
♪ should we leave crack open the window? ♪
♪ The bully in the classroom is like, ♪
♪ Chris no ♪
♪ I'm going to take out
a permanent marker ♪
♪ I put it on his beard ♪
♪ Make his mustache darker ♪
♪ I'm like, ahh, ♪
♪ this guy's a prick and
on the back of his head ♪
♪ I draw a massive dick ♪
♪ because he's bald ♪
♪ When you're young it's such fun ♪
♪ I make it up with the flowers, ♪
♪ Chrysanthemum ♪
♪ I say, so sorry, ♪
♪ I start apologizing ♪
♪ I go to the florist ♪
♪ and they're providing ♪
♪ a nice little bouquet maybe for a mum ♪
♪ Why? ♪
♪ Cause they're called Chrysanthe-mum ♪
♪ It's fun it's got a
nice little pun in there ♪
♪ If you are a little cat
owned by Schrödinger ♪
♪ Tough luck ♪
♪ Yeah its been said
that you won't be alive ♪
♪ and you will not be dead. ♪
♪ You're in the kind of
big state, half between ♪
♪ kind of carried on the little membrane ♪
♪ It's obscene ♪
♪ that he would treat that cat ♪
♪ put it there in the box, ♪
♪ get a tiny little hammer ♪
♪ And it would knock upon the outside ♪
♪ of some uranium ♪
♪ As a physicist he
was like, it such fun ♪
♪ to kill tiny little animals ♪
(laughter)
♪ The fun it provides ♪
♪ Gotta do it, how many times? ♪
♪ they got nine lives ♪
♪ And so you have fun of course ♪
♪ you could use a dead cat or
you could flog a dead horse ♪
♪ If you're Amish ♪
(audience laughs)
[Crosstalk]
♪ I'll be pulling all the
tractor and getting the yields ♪
♪ and I reveal to the others ♪
♪ They're not as good as me ♪
♪ I'm like Amish, shun electricity ♪
♪ We don't like the lights ♪
♪ We don't like the candles ♪
♪ We don't like a tractor ♪
♪ that's not pulled at that
the angle about this height ♪
♪ Do you understand? ♪
♪ Put the furrows in the land ♪
♪ and the horse with the hands ♪
♪ you can measure that ♪
♪ and pulling up all of the grain ♪
♪ I put in all the seeds ♪
♪ and sowing is insane ♪
♪ I want to go somewhere
warmer but not Spain ♪
♪ So it's the Philippines
and who can blame me? ♪
♪ I'm there walking
around the dead of night ♪
♪ I'm like, oh it's so fun ♪
♪ I'm the first- white ♪
(audience cheers)
♪ (indistinct) looking all around ♪
♪ why's he even there ♪
♪ what has he found? ♪
♪ Is he looking for something? ♪
♪ A girl that's cute? ♪
♪ Is he over there searching
for a prostitute? ♪
♪ Well, maybe ♪
♪ He's out there in Manila
and what's his skin color? ♪
♪ Kind of like vanilla. ♪
(audience cheers and claps)